hey everyone it's sarah with
registerednessaurian.com and in this
video i'm going to be going over a
comprehensive dosage calculations review
and what i'm going to be covering are
all of these different types of
calculations that you want to know as a
nurse now whenever you're done watching
this video you can access the free quiz
that will give you a comprehensive
review over these calculations so let's
get started first we're going to work
some basic conversion problems and this
really lays the foundation for us being
able to solve dosage calculations so
what we'll do is we'll build upon this
and as we go on these problems will
become more complex now before you even
start working dosage calculations you
have to commit to memory that metric
table and here's an example of the
metric table so you want to take this
information and you want to put it in
your brain because you're going to be
pulling from this table to help you
solve these problems now let's work our
first problem so it says 9 ounces equals
how many milliliters so we're trying to
figure out how many milliliters are in
nine ounces and i'm going to be using
dimensional analysis to work our
problems so we're gonna go ahead and set
that up so we know that we have nine
ounces
and we need to figure out how many
milliliters this is our destination this
is where we're getting so we're going to
pull from the metric table we know that
in one ounce
there is 30 milliliters
oh so we're there we've arrived to our
destination so we're going to cancel out
our ounces because that cancels out and
we're going to multiply everything at
the top everything at the bottom and
then divide and we have our answer so 9
times 30 is 270
and then 1 times one is one when you
divide that out you get
270. so 9 ounces equals 270 milliliters
now we're going to work our next problem
it says 30 milligrams equals how many
micrograms so we're trying to figure
that out again we'll set up our problem
using dimensional analysis so we say 30
milligrams
and we've got to ask ourselves using the
metric table how many
milligrams equals micrograms so we know
one
milligram
equals a thousand
micrograms
and that is where we're supposed to get
that's our destination so milligrams
cancels out we're going to multiply
everything at the top everything at the
bottom and then divide so 30 times a
thousand
is 30
000 and 1 times 1 is 1 divide that out
you get 30
000. so 30 milligrams equals 30 000
micrograms our next problem says 10
teaspoons equals how many milliliters so
let's set our problem up again with
dimensional analysis so ten teaspoons
and pulling from the metric table we
know that one
teaspoon
equals five milliliters so that cancels
out our teaspoons and we've arrived
where we need to get
so multiply everything at the top and
bottom and divide so 10 times 5 is 50
and then 1 times 1 of course is 1 and so
our answer is 50. 10 teaspoons equals 50
milliliters then over here our next
problem says 0.5 grams equals how many
micrograms so let's go ahead and set our
problem up using dimensional analysis so
0.5 grams
and we have to think back to our metric
table we know that there is
one gram
in a thousand
milligrams
and grams cancels out but we're not done
because we have to get to micrograms so
we need to do one more step
so we know that in one milligram
there is a thousand micrograms
so we have arrived that's where we need
to get was micrograms so milligrams
cancels out over here
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to multiply everything at the top
and everything at the bottom so 0.5
times a thousand times a thousand is
500 000
and then all of this multiplied together
is one so our answer is 500 000
micrograms
now some of you had some questions in my
previous video where we did basic
conversions and you're like well can i
do it this way like maybe go with like
for instance this problem
we went from ounces and we went straight
to milliliters but if you pulled from
the metric table this is what's really
cool about dimensional analysis you
could have went from ounces and then
went to tablespoons and then eventually
you could have got to milliliters so it
would sort of look something like this
like a little three step like that and
our last conversion problem says 170
pounds equals how many kilograms so
we're going to set up with dimensional
analysis so 170
pounds
and we know that from the metric table
there's 2.2
pounds in one kilogram and that's where
we need to get was the kilograms so
pounds cancels out we're going to
multiply and divide
so 170 times 1 is 170 and 1 times 2.2 is
2.2 now we're going to divide 170
divided by 2.2
is 77.2727
repeating
and i'm gonna round to the nearest tenth
and you always wanna make sure that you
follow your program's rounding rules for
how they want you to round these
problems now we're gonna work in oral
liquid medication problem and this
problem says that the doctor writes an
order for a medication that is in an
oral suspension the order reads to
administer 50 milligrams by mouth every
four hours as needed for pain your
dispense with a bottle that reads 25
milligrams per two mls how many
teaspoons will you administer per dose
so this is the important information we
need to pull from this problem in order
to solve so again we are solving for
teaspoons per dose so let's set up using
dimensional analysis so the doctor
orders 50 milligrams every four hours so
50 milligrams
is how much the patient needs to receive
in this oral suspension
we have a bottle of this medication that
says for every two milliliters that
you're pouring out there's 25 milligrams
of this medication
so
we're going to put 25 milligrams down
here
and we have 25 milligrams equals 2 ml of
medicine
this cancels out our milligrams now we
have to get to teaspoons so we're not
done
so we're looking at the metric table for
this so we know that in five
milliliters there's one
teaspoon this cancels out milliliters
and we are where we need to be so
multiply and divide so 50 times 2 is a
hundred
and 25 times five is 125
we divide that out and we get 0.8
it will be teaspoons per dose
is our answer now let's work a capsule
and tablet problem so our problem says
the doctor writes an order for
medication the order reads administer
0.5 milligrams by mouth daily you're
dispensed with a bottle that says 100
micrograms per tablet how many tablets
will you administer per dose so we've
pulled important stuff out that we need
to know about this problem in order to
solve so we need to figure out how many
tablets we're going to give this patient
based on what the doctor ordered the
doctor ordered 0.5 milligrams and we
have a bottle of tablets that says every
tablet
is a hundred micrograms so let's set up
our problem using dimensional analysis
so doctor ordered .5 milligrams
and we're supplied with some tablets
that are in micrograms so we have to get
to micrograms right now
so from our metric table we know that in
one milligram there are a thousand
micrograms
that cancels out the milligrams
and now we can plug in
our amount that we're supplied with
so we have we know that there are a
hundred
micrograms in one
tablet
micrograms cancels out and that's where
we need to get was tablets so we're
ready to solve multiply and divide so
0.5 times a thousand is 500
all this down here 1 times 1 times 100
is 100
and then we divide that out and our
answer is 5. so
we're going to give the patient five
tablets now we're going to solve an iv
bolus problem and this problem says the
doctor writes an order for an iv
medication that reads administer one
milligram iv now you're dispensed with a
vial that contains 0.4 milligrams per ml
how many mls will you draw up to
administer so here's the important
information we need to know to solve the
problem and we're trying to figure out
how many milliliters we're going to
withdraw from this vial to equal out a 1
milligram dose because our vial says for
every milliliter that is in this vial it
equals 0.4 milligrams so let's set up
our problem so the doctor ordered one
milligram
and
we need to get to milliliters so we know
that from our vial that it contains 0.4
milligrams in every milliliter
that cancels out milligrams and we are
ready to solve so 1 times 1 is 1 1 times
0.4 is 0.4
and we're going to divide out and we get
2.5
and that's how many milliliters we would
withdraw now we're going to solve some
different types of iv flow rate problem
so the first one we're going to look at
we're going to try to solve for drops
per minute so this problem says the
doctor writes an order to infuse a
solution the order reads infuse two
liters of d5 half normal saline with 50
ml equivalents of potassium chloride
over 48 hours the drip factor is 15
drops per ml
how many drops per minute will be
administered so we've pulled the most
important information from our problem
and if you notice in our problem it gave
us some distractors it told us that
there was 50 milli equivalents of
potassium chloride in this bag of fluids
and don't let that confuse you where
you're thinking oh no where do i plug
this 50 in at because it's just a
distractor to throw you off all you need
to know is that you're giving two liters
of fluid it does have 50 ml equivalents
of potassium chloride in it but you're
going to give that two liters over 48
hours now this problem also tells us a
drip factor drip factors come from your
iv tubing and here in this bag it told
us that our drip factor is 10 drops per
milliliter for this specific iv tubing
but for our problem it's telling us that
for every milliliter that's going to be
drop it's also called a drop factor
there's going to be 15 drops so we're
trying to solve for drops per minute
that's where we're trying to get
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
go ahead and convert
our hours into minutes because that's
where we're heading so let's go ahead
and do that with our dimensional
analysis so we know that in one
hour
there are 60 minutes
and our problem tells us
that we're going to give this solution
over 48 hours so we're going to go ahead
put 48 here and we're going to give 2
liters this cancels our hours and we
have minutes so we're almost there to
drops per minute
so we need to plug our drip factor in
but notice our drip factor is in
milliliters so we have to get there
because right now we're in liters so
we're going to pull from our metric
table
and we know that in one liter
there are a thousand
milliliters so that cancels liter liters
out so we're in milliliters but we got
to get here
so now we're going to plug in rest of
our information about our drip factor
so we know
that one
milliliter
is going to equal us 15 drops
so that cancels that out
and we are where we need to be we have
drops per minute we're ready to multiply
and divide so multiply everything at the
top we get thirty
thousand multiply everything at the
bottom we get two thousand eight hundred
and eighty
and when we divide that out we get ten
point
four
repeating
and i'm going to round to the nearest
whole number so our answer is 10 drops
per minute our next iv flow rate problem
is going to deal with solving for the
hourly rate such as milliliters per hour
so this problem says the doctor writes
an order to infuse a solution the order
reads infuse two liters of d5 half
normal saline over 48 hours what is the
hourly rate milliliters per hour so
here's our important information we need
to know we're trying to get to
milliliters per hour that is our
destination
so we know that the doctor has ordered
two liters to infuse in over 48 hours
so we need to get to milliliters per
hour so we're already here in hours but
we need to get this to milliliters so we
know from our metric table that there is
one liter in a thousand
milliliters
that cancels out our liters and look
we're here milliliters per hour so we
are ready to solve so multiply
everything and divide so two times a
thousand is two thousand forty eight
times 1 is 48 and when you divide 2000
by 48
you get one i mean you get
41.66 repeating and i'm going to round
to the nearest whole number and again
follow your programs rules for rounding
and our answer is 42 milliliters per
hour now let's solve an iv flow rate
problem that wants us to solve for the
infusion time so when will this infusion
actually be completed so our problem
says the doctor writes an order to
infuse a solution the order reads infuse
two liters of normal saline at 150
milliliters per hour you start the
infusion at eight o'clock and this is
eight in the morning this is written in
military time at what time will the
infusion be complete so the important
information we got from this problem is
that the physician wants us to infuse
two liters at an hourly rate of 150
milliliters per hour so every hour that
patient is going to be receiving 150
milliliters of fluid but they only need
two liters of fluid to go in and we
started the infusion at 8 am so when
will this order be complete
that's what we're looking for so let's
set up dimensional analysis
patients ordered two leaders
and
the physician wants to go that to go in
at a hourly rate of 150 milliliters per
hour
so notice we're here milliliters and
we're over here we're in liters so we
got to use our metric table to get over
there to milliliters so we know from the
metric table that in one liter there's a
thousand
milliliters so that cancels liters out
and we're going to go ahead and plug in
our hourly rate because we're ready to
and the position wants it to go in at
150 milliliters
in one hour
so that cancels our milliliters out and
we're in hours so we're ready to solve
because we need a time so this is going
to tell us the hours so two times a
thousand times one
is two thousand
and everything multiplied at the bottom
is one fifty
so two 000 divided by 150
gives us 13.33
repeating
hours
okay so we have that
but the problem is is we have leftover
hours so we need to know minutes because
we need to get a complete time for when
this infusion was done so we know it's
going to take 13 hours but let's convert
our left over hours in two minutes so we
get a complete time
so we'll go ahead and write 13
right here
so
0.33 hours because that's what we're
left with over here
and we know that
in one hour there's 60 minutes so here
we're at minutes and that's where we
need it to be so .33 times 60
gives us
19.8
and then 1 times 1 is 1 and then we're
going to round we're going to divide of
course that gives you 19.8 and then
we're going to round to the nearest
whole number so that gives us 20. so
it's going to take
13 hours and 20 minutes to infuse
but
it wants to know the time so 13 hours
and 20 minutes from 8am in the morning
would give us 9
20 pm but we need to write that in
military time because that's how we give
time in the medical field so military
time for that would be
2120 and that is equal to
9 20
pm and that is our answer now we're
going to solve a weight based
calculation so this problem says the
doctor orders an iv weight based
medication to infuse at two micrograms
per kilogram per minute the patient
weighs 130 pounds you are supplied with
a bag of the iv medication that reads
250 milligrams per 250 mls how many
milliliters per hour will you administer
so we've pulled the most important
information from our problem to solve
and we're trying to figure out how much
milliliters per hour we're going to give
this patient from this iv bag of
medication and this medication is based
on the patient's weight so the doctor
wants us to give two micrograms per
minute for every kilogram the patient
weighs we're told the patient weighs 130
pounds so right there you know you're
going to have to get from pounds to
kilograms
and we have a bag that is in
milligrams the order is in micrograms so
we know we're going to be doing some
converting there and our bag is a 250
milliliter bag and in that bag we have
250
milligrams so let's set up and solve so
first thing we're going to do right off
the bat is we're going to deal with this
pounds and we're going to get to
kilograms so we can start plugging in
our doctor's order so our patient weighs
130 pounds
and we know from the metric table that
there's 2.2 pounds
in one kilogram so there we go we have
dealt with that now let's plug in what
the physician has ordered so for every
kilogram the patient weighs
we're going to give two
micrograms
per minute
so that cancels out our kilograms
now we can plug in what we are supplied
with because we can start converting
there
so we're actually in micrograms right
now we have to get to milligrams so
we're going to plug in that metric table
once again and we know that in a
thousand
micrograms there's one milligram cancels
out micrograms so we're done with
micrograms
we can plug in what we have so we have
250 milligrams in a 250
ml bag that cancels out milligrams and
we have to get milliliters to hours
right now we're in milliliters per
minute but we're going to go ahead and
solve everything and then we'll convert
our hours to minutes
so
we're going to multiply 130 times 1
times 2 times 1 times 250 and that gives
us 65
000.
then we're going to do 1 times 2.2 times
1 times 1 000 times 250 and that gives
us 550
000.
then we're going to divide that out and
that's going to give us
eight 0.11818 eight repeating
so currently we're in milliliters per
minute that's not what our problem
wanted and one in milliliters per hour
because that's our rate we're going to
set our pump
so we're going to convert that
we know that there are 60 minutes
in one hour
so
this is currently in minutes
so one minute
is equal to this many milliliters so one
minute is equal to 0.11818
and that was repeating and their minutes
cancels out so we are now ready to solve
so 60 times
0.11818 gives us 7.0908
[Music]
and then of course 1 times 1 is 1 and
then when we mult divide that out
that gives us we're going to round to
the nearest whole number that gives us
seven so our answer is seven milliliters
per hour now we're going to solve
another weight based calculation but
we're going to apply that to the
medication heparin because i want you to
be able to see how to work a problem
like that so our problem says the doctor
orders your patient to start an iv
heparin drip at five units per kilogram
per hour and to administer a loading
bolus dose of 10 units per kilogram iv
before initiation of the drip you're
supplied with a heparin bag that reads
12 500 units per 250 ml the patient
weighs 110 pounds what is the flow rate
you will set the iv pump rate so here is
the important information we need to
know we're going to give five units per
hour for every kilogram the patient
weighs they weigh 110 pounds and we have
a bag that is a 250 ml bag and it
contains 12 500 units now notice that
this problem told you a loading dose to
give before you start the drip this can
be ordered with a heparin drip if the
physician orders it but don't let that
throw you off because that's just a
distractor once again
so let's figure out the milliliters per
hour how we're going to set our pump to
infuse so first thing what we're going
to do is we're going to deal with this
pounds we need to get to kilograms
because that's how this drug is ordered
it's weight based
so our patient weighs 110
pounds
we know from our metric table that
there's 2.2 pounds
and 1 kilogram so we're done with pounds
we're now in kilograms
and the order is for every kilogram the
patient weighs we're going to give them
five units per hour
so for every kilogram patient weighs
we're giving them five units
per hour kilograms cancels out
and now
we are ready to
put in what we're supplied with
so we have
we're told that
in this bag there's 12
500 units
in this 250
ml
bag so units cancels out and we're left
with milliliters per hour so we're ready
to solve so when you
multiply everything at the top you get
137
500
and multiply everything at the bottom
you get 27
[Music]
500 and then we're gonna divide that out
and whenever you divide that out you get
five so our answer is five milliliters
per hour now let's solve a pediatric
safe dosage problem where we're going to
figure out the safe range for this
pediatric patient based on the
recommendation and their weight so the
problem says the doctor orders an iv
drip for a child that weighs 78 pounds
the safe dosage range for the ordered
medication is 5 to 10 micrograms per
kilogram per minute what is the safe
dose range for this child so here is
important information when you know the
patient's weight and that recommended
safe dose range for the patient so we're
going to be working like a two-step
problem because we have to get two
different numbers and we're trying to
get to micrograms per minute so we know
their patient weighs say 78 pounds so
let's go ahead and deal with the weight
and get it to kilograms because that's
what our medication range is in so the
patient weighs 78 pounds
and we know from the metric table that
they are 2.2 pounds in one kilogram that
cancels out our pounds
and our dosage says that this child can
have
for every kilogram they weigh
5
micrograms
per minute so we're just dealing with
this five because that's the lowest part
of the rate the range and the 10 is the
highest part so we'll deal with the
lowest part first and we're ready to
solve because we are in
micrograms per minute our kilograms
canceled out so when you multiply
everything at the top you get 390
everything at the bottom 2.2
when you divide that out get 177.22
repeating and i'm going to round to the
nearest tenth so 177.3
that's the lowest part of this range but
now we have to get the high part so now
we're just going to plug in the 10 where
we did our five and set up the problem
so our patient weighs 78 pounds
we know that from the metric table
there's 2.2 pounds
and 1 kilogram cancels out pounds
know from our order that one kilogram
patient on the high end can receive 10
micrograms
per minute
we're where we need to be so our
kilograms cancels out we're going to
multiply and divide so when we multiply
everything at the top
we get
780.
everything at the bottom 2.2
when we divide that out we get 354.
repeating around to the nearest tenth so
that gives us 354.5
and this is the safe range for this
child based on the recommended dose and
their weight now we're going to work a
drug reconstitution problem and this
problem says the doctor orders 10
milligrams of a by-mouth medication that
needs to be reconstituted
instructions on the 0.25 gram container
say to reconstitute with water to make a
concentration of 0.5 grams per 3 ml
you would administer blank milliliters
per dose so here's the important
information we pulled from our problem
so we need to give 10 milligrams per
dose and we have a 0.25 gram container
and once it's reconstituted we're going
to have a dose of every three meals
equals point five grams so we're trying
to get two milliliters per dose how what
are we going to give this patient
so what we're going to do is we're going
to start with the amount ordered so the
doctor ordered 10 milligrams
per dose
so
we
have to get to grams and we're in
milligrams because that's what how much
is in this container once it was
reconstituted so we
know from their metric table that in 1
000
milligrams there's one gram
so milligrams cancels out
and we
are told that we have this
amount
so
0.5 grams
is equal to 3 milliliters and this is
how what its value is once it's been
reconstituted so grams cancels out and
we're left with milliliters per dose and
that's what we need to know how much we
need to give so
so now whenever you multiply everything
at the top and the bottom you're going
to get 30 and then on the bottom that
would be 500
and 30 divided by 500 is
0.06 so we are going to give
0.06 ml per dose now let's work a tube
feeding problem so our problem says the
patient is order jevity 1.2 cow you're
supplied with a can of gevity that
contains 337 milliliters of feeding
formula the doctor orders the tube
feeding to be administered at 3 4
strength with a rate of 50 ml per hour
how many milliliters of water will you
add to dilute the tube feeding formula
as prescribed to solve this two feeding
problem you have to memorize the
following equation and it's going to
help us solve for how many milliliters
of water that we're going to add to this
feeding formula to dilute it based on
what the doctor ordered the doctor
ordered a 3 4 strength and the doctor
also ordered for it to go in at a rate
of 50 mls per hour but we really don't
need that information to help us solve
this problem so we know that we have a
can and in the can it has a volume of
237 mls but we have to dilute that to a
3 4 string so this formula is going to
help us do it so what we're going to do
is we're going to plug in
our information so the milliliters in
the can
237
so 237 mls
we are solving for x x is the total
volume that is going to be administered
so we don't know what that is yet so
we're just going to put that there and
then the strength ordered is 3 4. so
we're going to put three
fourths now we're going to solve you're
going to multiply everything across from
each other so 237 times 4
is
948
and then
3 times x is 3x we're solving for x so
what we're going to do is we're going to
divide everything over here and
everything over there it's going to
cancel this 3 out so 3 divided by 3
is cancels it out and then 9 948 divided
by 3
gives us 316
okay so
316 mls
is our total volume that's what x told
us
but we need to know how much water we're
giving because this is how much we're
totally giving so how much of that is
water so to figure that out you just
take
316 which is the total volume subtract
that from the original can size which is
327
and you get 79 mls so we will give
79 mls of water now we're going to wrap
up this comprehensive review and we're
going to solve a body surface area
calculation so this problem says a
pediatric patient is ordered a
medication dose of 10 milligrams per
square meter per day by mouth for 7 days
the patient weighs 46 pounds and is 3
feet nine inches
what is the daily dose of medication the
patient will receive so we've pulled the
most important information from our
problem to help us solve and we are
trying to get to milligrams per day now
the special thing about this medication
is that it is ordered by the patient's
body surface area so it's telling us
that for every square meter the patient
needs 10 milligrams per day and this is
going to be based on their height and
their weight that's how we're going to
figure out the body surface area and to
do that there's a couple of equations
you can use and we're going to use this
one
and it tells us for what we're solving
for is the square meter so we're going
to take pounds multiply that by inches
divide that by 3131
and then we're going to find the square
root of that and that's going to be our
patients square meter their body surface
area now to do this you're going to need
a calculator that can solve the square
root so keep that in mind so we're going
to go ahead and figure that out and then
we're going to solve for the milligrams
per day using some dimensional analysis
and we'll get our answer
so let's go ahead and convert this so we
have 3 feet 9 inches we need all in
inches so let's go ahead and just figure
that out
so we know that there are 12 inches
in a foot so 12 times 3
gives us 36
but they're 3 foot 9. so we're going to
go ahead and add 9 because that's how
many left over inches we have so 36 plus
9 is 45
so our patient is 45 inches
so we have 45 inches 46 pounds we're
good to go ahead and plug into this
formula so let's just erase this and put
it in so 46 times 45
so what is that that gives us
2070
ahead and carry our square root down and
then we're going to divide that
by
3131 and when we do that we are going to
get
um
0.6
etc
and what we're going to do is figure the
square root out of that so you plug that
into your calculator
and once you do that you are going to
get
0.81 that's where we're going to round
and that gives us our square meter
so we have that information now let's
solve using dimensional analysis so
that's important for us to know
so the doctor has ordered
10 milligrams for every square meter the
patient weighs per day
so the patient's body surface area is
.81 square meter
and for every square meter the patient
is they need 10 milligrams
per day
square meter cancels out multiply
everything at the top and bottom and
divide
and once we do that we get
8.1 milligrams per
day
and that is our answer okay so that
wraps up this comprehensive review over
dosage calculations now if you would
like a more in-depth look at each of
these different categories i have in the
description below individual videos that
will explain more in depth on how to
work these problems and don't forget to
access the free quiz that will test you
on this material